das ist schon das ist schon sehr
emotional als ich dann mit meinem bett
herum gefahren und so durch die berge
ich hab schon tränen verdrückt etwa
herzlich konstanten wieder leute das
video das ihr heute jetzt hier seht ist
ein ausschnitt aus meinem dreht zusammen
mit luca ich habe mit lu calais mich
nicht nur sein auto getestet sondern
auch über einige themen geredet die mich
an ihm interessieren und eins von diesen
themen habt ihr heute in diesem video
leute ich wünsche euch viel spaß damit
und jetzt ab nach hamburg was bedeutet
das thema oldtimer für dich weil ich
habe haben sie bei dir auf insider und
den stories hat man schon gesehen dass
wir auch mal mitfährt ist es auch
spannend das ist gemeint hatte auch mal
ja sind oldtimer auch wasser was dich
interessiert sind jahrhundert aber das
was man im einst genannt sind keine
autos von mir jetzt nicht das irgendwie
war da draußen den jahren der bitte
schon oft gesehen du besitzt auch
mehrere oldtimer oder sind sie selbst
kein auto
er selbst habe keinen oldtimer
allerdings ist es so dass mein vater hat
eine große leidenschaft für hat ja wie
gesagt früher halt angefangen hat mit
einem ganz alten austin healey den als
selbst irgendwie umzubauen und sehr und
mit dem bin ich halt damals schon mal
mitgefangen ich kann mal gucken
vielleicht hat sie ein foto einen
blenden ob ich noch eins findet ja dann
sieht man das sind da ich war so voll am
strahlenden so aus niedereimer und keine
ahnung es gibt natürlich auch dass die
deutlich schneller sind und bei
oldtimern geht es auch nicht darum guck
mal ich bin von null auf hundert so
schnell
sondern es geht halten wir also um das
feeling das stück war sie so zum
beispiel mandat und ich wollten
eigentlich mit dem ilja mitfahren weil
mein vater einen alten 356 die waage
teil scheibe hat also einen relativ
alten porsche mit sage und schreibe 40
ps und wir haben uns schon vorher
informiert und millimeter sonne so ein
oldtimer rennen in italien durch italien
durch die frage unfassbar bekannt das
hat sonst so sehr krassen historischen
wert er und da ist es so dass haye macht
kommt jetzt von seiten des kosten für
[Gelächter]
gut dass wir autowaschen fahren bei dem
wetter sonne kurzfilm solch hupe testen
wollte er an die hupe klingt warum party
nicht ist noch grün ja also ich finde
bei oldtimern geht's halt nicht darum
dass man irgendwie hätte dass man
irgendwie jetzt so krass auf
da spielen wir ganz andere dinge
plötzlich eine rolle also ich bin das
letzte mal den 356 mit meinem dad
gefahren als wir uns durch bielefeld
durch die berge gefahren sind und dann
so eine schöne herbsttage dann einfach
so herum fahren mit 30 km h und priester
die richtig die abgase so das ist
einfach irgendwie das schon gaal hielt
sich nach freiheit also ja zu dem das
klingt und das habe ich in dem auto
nicht das ist jetzt klar wird sich jetzt
andere schlafen kannst du brauchst du
weißt was ich meine ich weiß was du
meinst so gut wollte in oldtimer
oldtimer sind haben wir den vorteil ist
losgelöst sind von so schneller weiter
länger als von den von diesen fakten
vergleichen was heute auch was bei autos
so wichtig ist
wer schneller von null auf hundert
mehr drehmoment und sofort da geht es
wie gesagt wir das ding 540 ps hat ja
und da auch im winter keinen stich im
kopf dazu ja vor allem die tatsache dass
du halt nicht irgendwie dann viele skoda
du hast gerade hat gerade den dass die e
klasse die gerade mit dem handy
ausgemacht
oder ich habe hier dann assistenzsysteme
und wenn das passiert dann bremst
automatisch ab und keine ahnung hast ja
das hast du da halt nicht mehr für den
listen schlüssel und muss neid
reinstecken muss das irgendwie mit
zwischengas musst du das ding erstmal
fahren können vor allem dann wenn da
irgendwas nicht funktioniert hast du
nicht irgendwie eine nadel die irgendwie
anzeige oder digital hey das und das
muss ausgetauscht werden sondern du
merkt einfach dass der motor nicht mehr
gut schalte das könnte öl liegen doch es
ist halt einfach ganz ganz anders
deutlich geiler finde ich aber für den
alltag einfach nicht gemacht ja
vielleicht nicht richtiger aber wenn man
mal die zeit hat und so die möglichkeit
zu fahren das ist wirklich ein ganz
anderes fahren und sehr sehr interessant
ja ich glaube auch wirklich wenn
personen sich überhaupt nicht für autos
interessieren
sobald man einmal in seinem oldtimer
sitzt und es muss ja auch kein
geisteskranker 300 sl plötzlich sei der
millionen von euros kostet sondern gibt
ja auch schon oldtimer mittlerweile mit
h-kennzeichen die die krise fast schon
nicht mal fünfstellig so alte gelten ja
auf jeden fall 30 jahre können wir
glaube ich eine kennzeichen ärgert mich
nicht fest leute ich meine brauchen
keine ahnung aber ich glaube wenn man
einmal da drin gesessen hat und halt
weiß okay den autos nicht ein
fortbewegungsmittel von wegen ich will
von punkt a nach punkt b kommen sondern
es kommt darauf an wie ich einfach vom
punkt a nach punkt b komme und einfach
auch mal sich sonntag frei nehmen
einfach umfahren da die umwelt bedankt
sich so aber das ist schon das ist schon
sehr emotional
also als ich dann mit meinem bett herum
gefahren und so durch die berge ich bin
ich hab schon die tränen verdrückt
das ist richtig schön hatte das ist geil
das ist das ist wirklich geil genau
darum geht es her dass man auch die
leute
findet ihr auch eine leidenschaft für
das thema finde ich richtig richtig dass
man ja am liebsten würde ich jetzt
natürlich sagen ich hole mir papa dann
startet man mit ihm irgendwie mit dem
alten fans aber passt halt so voll
ja ja denn der hat ja nichts mit youtube
nutzer das muss immer fragen aber das
wäre natürlich bei der mann in dem auto
drin sitzt schon besitzt halt so du hast
halt nicht nur lehne bisher solle bis
hier so gefühlt also den kopf wenn und
unverbraucht halt so wie du fährst halt
auch nicht schneller als 50 km/h
alles wackelt halt irgendwie sogar das
krasseste ist halt wirklich so das ist
halt so und beim schalten also ich bin
eher relativ groß gewachsen
denn die kupplung durchtritt tut richtig
weh weil du stehst du immer das knie an
diesem wenn diese verkleidung so weit
unten das heißt ich hatte nachher
richtig blaue flecken und so mit dem
schalten irgendwie sodann und damit
zwischengas damit er nicht ab kratzt und
so das ist schon eine ganz andere liga
du musst du dich am arbeiten so kann man
muss wirklich zwischengas geben also
tritt dann wollte ich auch der letzte
bleibt das thema wie wichtig ist das
thema anders statement für dich gerade
bei allgemein im leben aber auch bei
autos also ja wie schon gesagt also ich
könnte jetzt nicht vorstellen außer wenn
man vielleicht mal irgendwo auf der
rennstrecke geht oder so sondern gt3 hat
beispielsweise im alltag zu fahren die
sache ist nämlich sagt für den ähnliches
fahrzeug wert könnte man ja auch autos
fand ich viel viel auffälliger sind weil
ich damit etwas was ich ein rolls royce
oder sowas steht jetzt noch nicht genau
die preise der neuen benzin oder sowas
oder 458 4 88 ferrari oder so alle roma
beispielsweise ja er hatte ganz neu ja
dieses jahr viel viel krasser also in
der hinsicht ist branche porsche das ist
natürlich eine geile mark und sein sagt
auch viel aus aber es ist ja nicht die
marke die wie lamborghini oder ferrari
schreit ja hier bin ich habe mich alle
an also das auto hat hier in der
konfiguration die ich habe 260.000 euro
gekostet kraft und da kriegst du auf
jeden fall ganz andere autos wird zum
beispiel der neue gt3 der costa hat
deutlich weniger
und der wäre halt deutlich lauter um der
zither nicht bis 8.000 bis 10.000 auf
motor deutlich mehr emotionen halt
einfach pt 3
dadurch dass er dann aber nur
hinterradantrieb hat hat er zum beispiel
von den werten ist er deutlich langsamer
als der hier gibt die aber dafür viel
mehr was emotionen angeht lautstärke
generell rennsport feeling ist quasi
rennsport für mit straßenzulassung ja
und das hat das ding das ich mir so was
im alltag überhaupt nicht vorstellen
könnte aber dieses auto halt wirklich
und dafür steht halt diese 911 turbo
oder turbo s -reihe halt einfach
geändert ist halt turbolader also ist
halt deutlich leiser dadurch aber
deutlich mehr leistung auch durch die
turbolader und was ich halt einfach
möchte es ich will ein auto fahren was
ich quasi im alter komplett fahren kann
also ich kann hier leute also zur not
mal eine person noch mitnehmen beim
koffer hinten rein und aktenkoffer
vornherein packen und dann ganz normal
gegend herumfahren oder das irgendwie
komisch guckt so wenn du mit dem ferrari
vorfeld und auf dem dach so mäßig und
dass es mir halt wichtig aber an das
statement an sich also ich bin da sehr
vorsichtig was so dinge in sachen angeht
zeigen auch dass ja auch ein sehr lange
deine autos auch privat halten und
vielleicht auch ein anderer punkt du
warst ja auch schon sehr lange auch kraß
auf youtube und so bis mäßigem start
bist aber da auch sehr sehr sehr lange
kannst du sagen wenn ich kann es denn
sehen wenn du nicht magst den nächsten
video ja zum beispiel mini gefahren
was jetzt nicht die oberste jetzt habe
ich auch selbst gesagt glaube ich mal
irgendwann ja nichts passieren ja du
bist ja ist ja selbst lange mini
gefahren als du auch sagen wir vom geld
her auch ganz andere autos hätte es
locker fahren können
also wie war es eigentlich nie da sorgen
damit für mich war es damals das hat
jetzt zwar nicht viel mit autos zu tun
solange sich das thema aber für mich war
es schon immer so dass ich um da hat
mich mein vater habe auch sehr gut
erzogen was das angeht immer erst die
wichtigsten sachen regeln und danach
hast du zeit für luxus und alles on top
und zum beispiel war es so dass ich mir
gesagt habe ich will erst irgendwie
markenklamotten tragen oder erst
irgendwie mir einen wunsch erfüllen was
auch immer so langsam wie möglich durch
das ding durch
denn ich quasi ja weiß okay das was ich
wirklich brauche habe ich und als ich
mir dann die wohnung damals gekauft hat
in köln ja und ich wusste ich muss quasi
keine miete mehr zahlen sondern wohnen
hier
dann hatte ich zeit für sachen die ein
bisschen ohne tiger sind sage ich mal
ich weiß auch dass der pkw peugeot 206
cc ja gar nicht meine etwas was ich aber
dass also habe ich mir von so witzig wie
man mit dieser karte weil diese zu
gefühlt gerade beifahrersitz in meiner
wohnung in köln im erdgeschoss soll man
den straßen daneben gepackt das wurde
bei mir während der gamescom auf dem
sofa gepäck aber also den 206 cc habe
ich auch komplett selbst bezahlt
natürlich aber den habe ich mich gehasst
hat für mich eine scheiß könnte also
muss ich gesteht mir das tool läuft also
ehrlich mich auch sein denn habe ich
nicht gemacht habe
also ich sage mal ganz ehrlich wäre ich
an deiner stelle gewesen hätte ich mir
schon dickere autos gezogen insofern ist
es aus meiner perspektive war ich halt
auch irgendwie so gern
keine ahnung was ich sagen will ist dass
ich manchmal keine reflexe bin und gerne
mal den dicken mache aber machen den
kleinen sprung zu dem zeitpunkt wo luca
erzielt welches auto er sich nach seinem
mini nach seinem ersten eigenen auto
geholt hat das war nämlich auch schon
ein 911 aber nicht der turbo ist hier in
diesem video ja dann habe ich mir den
911 targa gekauft und habe den wirklich
weil ich mich scheiße gefühlt habe für
dieses auto weil ich quasi nur dieser
die youtuber bin da meine videos mache
und finde es ehrlich leid immer noch
unfertigen damit verdient
schon krass aussagen ist ja wirklich ja
aber dann kannst du hast du das war ganz
gut erklärt und das ist immer noch bei
mir im kopf drin denn die nachfrage also
ein los damals noch nicht so gesagt den
arbeitgeber zeit dem arbeitnehmer immer
so viel wie er denkt dass die leistung
hat wert ist hierher bringt oder
irgendwas so was kennt jedes gehalt
jeder entlohnung ist eine funktion von
angebot und nachfrage
und es gibt leute die finden das
vielleicht droht aber die tatsache dass
es jetzt so ist belegt schon dass es
sehr sehr wenige leute in deutschland
gibt die auf dem niveau youtube social
media und alles drum und dran machen wie
du es machst du bist ja ganz klar einer
der größten aller erfolgreichsten und
die allerwenigsten leute da draußen
würden auch sagen ja nee wenn ich die
möglichkeit habe das zu verdienen dann
mache ich nicht weil ich das moralisch
falsch finde so ist es ja auch nicht das
ist einfach das sind schon einfach
krasse dimensionen das ist wahr aber ist
halt auch alles selbst erarbeitet und
niemand kam irgendwann dann zudem hat
gesagt ja hey wir schenken die jetzt so
mix oder so dafür weil du einfach so ein
toller kerl ist und dann machen wir
einen kleinen deckel drauf leute ich
werde jetzt in zukunft öfter so machen
dass ich am sonntag die die auto videos
mit den leuten gropper und dann unter
der woche so videos wo ich über themen
reden ich an den gästen spannend finde
das hier heute soweit eventuell kommt
morgen noch ein talk video mit luca und
am sonntag dann das neue auto testen
ich bin darüber fleißig und stein für
euch und bis morgen oder übermorgen